sie wollen nämlich die alten wieder zum
Arbeiten holen und haben sich da was
ganz besonderes
Hamburg alle in einem vielleicht
aber wir sind ja schon ein bisschen
bejaht
nichts anderes mal so und damit auch
erfahren und dann komme ich zu meiner
These wir lassen wir haben in
Deutschland 1,7 Millionen ähm
offene Stellen zurzeit in etwa dann die
nicht registrierten nicht mitgezählt wir
haben ein Fachkräftemangel und darüber
hinaus auch im Dienstleistungsbereich
enorme Mangelerscheinung gleichzeitig
haben wir einen Sinn stehen wir bei
einem Renten in einem Rentensystem in
dass wir bereits in diesem Jahr das ist
ja beginnt mit 13 Milliarden aus dem
steuersättel die Deckel entdecken müssen
und das nimmt zu heute arbeiten also
zwei Personen zwei tätige sozusagen für
einen Rentner später werden es 2050 wenn
das so weitergeht mit der Demografie ist
ein Beschäftigter für einen Rentner
zuständig wollen sie das seit 30%
Beitrag zahlt oder 40%, das werden die
Leute ihnen nicht durchgehen lassen da
wird es ein Problem das heißt wir müssen
dieses Potenzial und das ist eine ganz
grundsätzliche Frage ich finde in
unserer Gesellschaft gibt es einen alten
Bashing das hat viele Ursachen der alte
graue weißhaarige Mann die Umweltsau die
zuständig ist mit ihrem Mann zusammen
dass sie diesen Wohlstand aufgebaut
haben die sind ja Schuldner
Klimakatastrophe die Leute die dieses
Land mühsam aufgearbeitet haben nach 45
die werden heute von den Kopf gestoßen
die sollen wir haben nur noch wenig Zeit
deswegen jemand ein bisschen
reingekommen in der Bundesrepublik sind
zur Zeit über 30% der Rentner unter 75
65 bis 75 von denen sind viele bereits
sofort
zu helfen dran zu gehen übrigens werden
die fleißiger sein also manche junge so
kann ich Ihnen sagen die haben noch
nicht über live Balance in ihrem sagen
wir haben dieses Land schon mal
aufgebaut um das ganz klar zu sagen und
diese Leute werden bereit wenn man ihnen
eine Chance gibt und meinen Vorschlag
wäre auch an Sie als Parlamentarier der
CDU Steuerfreiheit für jeden Rentner der
sich wenn es nur stundenweise ist in
einem Betrieb begibt als Verkäuferin als
Kfz-Mechaniker egal was auch immer
öffnet dieses Potenzial
öffnen
und der Anreiz ist steuerfrei und ich
kann mir noch was dazu verdienen für den
Kneipenbesuch für mein Hobby für was
auch immer sofort ich bin mittendrin ich
werde ihn dreieinhalb Monaten 75 und
habe mich oder Frau Schuber richtig
sympatisch
und deswegen sage ich ja ich freue mich
über jede Arbeit und das ist heute keine
Arbeit das ist ein Vergnügen aber ich
freue mich wenn ich noch gefragt bin
weil das auch mit dem ganz persönlichen
lebenswert etwas zu tun hat dass man
sich noch für diese Gesellschaft wird
dafür ich bin sehr dafür dass die
Senioren oder die
Älteren in unserem Land auch arbeiten
dass wir alles dafür tun dass sie
arbeiten können und Anreize geschaffen
werden genau
völlig unter umstritten ne wenn deswegen
ja sehr dafür ne weil wir brauchen die
Älteren und die alten Bashing was manche
machen da bin ich völlig dagegen das ist
absolut falsch die haben viel Erfahrung
genau aber Stopp jetzt kommt der
entscheidende Punkt
ist man kann nicht sein wie du die
müssen gar keine Steuern zahlen das wäre
extrem ungerecht es gibt Familien die
haben wenig Geld die müssen dann viel
Steuern zahlen und andere gar keine
deswegen bin ich eher dafür dass wir
insgesamt die Steuern für alle etwas
denken
ältere die noch arbeiten wollen noch
arbeiten können und wer solange das auf
der Freiwilligkeit beruht habe ich da
überhaupt kein Problem
naja ich zahle auch Steuern
heute sozusagen gibt ja Anreize gibt ja
Staffelung oder was kein Problem ist
eher wenn Menschen so eine geringe Rente
haben dass sie sich gezwungen fühlen
auch noch in nach der Rente arbeiten zu
müssen dann irgendwie
in dieser Runde doch ein bisschen
Frieden geschlossen